President Joe Biden made a visit to
Ukraine yesterday and it was a
completely reasonable visit it was the
indication that Joe Biden and his
security team aren't scared to go to
Kiev where there were air raid sirens in
the background of the visit with the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
and yet Republicans are absolutely
Furious some even border borderline
defending Vladimir Putin as Putin has
suspended the new start treaty the most
belligerent signal recently since the
invasion of Ukraine that he may indeed
be going in the direction of at least
considering the use of nuclear weapons
in this conflict and it is difficult to
know where to start but let's maybe
start with the statements from Vladimir
Putin the Associated Press reports
Russia suspends only remaining major
nuclear treaty with the U.S
Russian President Vladimir Putin
declared Tuesday that Moscow was
suspending its participation in the new
start treaty the last remaining nuclear
arms control pact with the United States
sharply upping the ante amid tensions
with Washington over the fighting in
Ukraine Vladimir Putin made the
statement during his state of the nation
address during which he also said Russia
should stand ready to resume nuclear
weapons tests if the U.S does so a move
that would end a global ban on nuclear
weapons tests in place since Cold War
times this is not a coincidence in terms
of its timing Joe Biden yesterday in
Ukraine and Putin today of course we're
adjusting for the time difference today
saying these things this is a very real
threat we now have the possibility of
China aiding Russia that is increasingly
in the background of the discussion and
the United States in the midst of that
trying to figure out and when I say that
I don't mean trying to figure out as if
the answer is obvious I don't mean like
Trump's trying to figure out how tariffs
work well we know how tariffs work we
are genuinely trying to see
what possible diplomatic paths forward
there are
while continuing to support Ukraine
militarily
as this is an aggression by Russia
although some on the right don't want to
accept that but meanwhile many
Republicans and we're not going to look
through every example because I don't
have three hours to just play these
clips for you Republicans criticizing
Joe Biden for um this trip to Ukraine
and remember that with a lot of these
things it's always we're going to
criticize no matter what Biden hasn't
gone to the Border Kamala hasn't gone to
the Border they go well they went late
and also to the wrong City On the Border
well but they went but no but that shows
they don't really care I thought not
going showed they didn't care well no
going but to the wrong place at the
wrong time also shows they don't care
they just want to criticize but it's
becoming increasingly pathetic and
concerning from the standpoint of do
these Republicans even hold as a
priority what's best for the United
States and our people here is Republican
Congresswoman Nancy mace saying you know
it was President's Day to go to Ukraine
instead of Ohio it it was President's
Day after all burned salad if you ask me
uh kind of an embarrassment on the world
stage and to be in Ukraine on
President's Day as was just mentioned
rather than going to Ohio where
Americans really are suffering on one of
the largest environmental disasters in
my lifetime at least it is an
embarrassment and this so I thought
Americans were primarily suffering Nancy
and Republicans
from high uh from inflation from high
energy prices and other sorts of
economic instability directly linked to
what's going on in Ukraine no now that's
not important because you have to say it
was wrong for Biden to go and instead he
should have gone to Ohio so now Ohio
becomes really where people are
suffering now of course they're they're
suffering elsewhere uh there's always
suffering elsewhere and Joe Biden's no
longer in the basement but he's in the
wrong place so that's bad as well why
didn't he go to the Border yesterday I
mean it's President's Day after all so
this is we've talked about this before
this is like running through a cancer
fundraiser and screaming what about
Parkinson's are you all ignored don't
you care about Parkinson's and then you
go to the Parkinson's fundraiser and you
say every last one of you should be
ashamed of yourselves that you're doing
nothing about AIDS do you know about
AIDS and you're talking about
Parkinson's this is always it's very
tired it's very low brow it's very
transparent but they can always do this
and they often do when they don't want
to have to praise the actions of a
Democrat Donald Trump also held an event
yesterday in Palm Beach we're going to
look at this event more extensively
later but there was one moment where
Donald Trump also same line criticized
Biden for going to Ukraine but not to
Ohio done in two years nobody's ever
seen anything like it and even now you
have a president going to Ukraine and
you have people in Ohio that are in
desperate need of help and I was very
proud to say that I announced I was
going to Ohio you know FEMA said we're
not going to give many he was proud of
himself about the announcement that he
made okay the Biden Administration said
we're not going to give him anything and
then I announced I'm going please sit
down yeah go ahead sir we'll be here for
a while what do we have to do
why do we have to yeah it's not like
Trump's running a campaign or anything
anyway so Trump also criticizing Biden
for going to Ukraine instead of Ohio and
then everybody's favorite uh traitorous
congresswoman Marjorie Trader green
tweeted quote Biden didn't go to East
Palestine Ohio on President's Day again
I don't know why it matters that it's
President's Day it's this very strange
thing Biden didn't go to East Palestine
Ohio on President's Day he went to
Ukraine a non-nato nation whose leader
is an actor I mean okay so our leader
for a while was just a real estate dude
and is apparently now commanding our
United States military to World War we
must impeach this America last full
before it's too late so completely
unhinged and pathetic uh Biden should be
impeached because he went to Ukraine if
you can imagine something as absurd as
this so that's the latest we're going to
delve more deeply into the Putin nukes
stuff the Biden trip as it went beyond
Ukraine uh heading to Poland we're going
to talk about all of it as the week
continues let's now talk about
the train derailment you know I'm not
sure where people are getting that
nobody's talking about the train
derailment everywhere I look I see
stories about the train derailment local
media National media New York Times and
Washington Post CNN and Fox News
Independent Media Twitter Reddit
everywhere I look people are talking
about the train derailment so for the
people emailing me saying David why is
no one talking about it I see everyone
talking about it and one of the things
that we are learning as that talking
continues is that the train derailment
story is quickly building and building
pointing more and more in the direction
of sadly being a story about regulation
and I know that the right hates this the
right wants to argue
that businesses have a an incentive to
regulate themselves why wouldn't they
right I mean because if they don't
regulate themselves and something bad
happens then it's terrible for PR except
a lot of these companies don't really
depend on PR in the sense of a consumer
facing businesses so it doesn't really
apply and we know from endless examples
from history that it simply doesn't work
that way we have an article here
um from Freight waves which covers the
um train industry I guess we would say
Norfolk Southern eliminated key
maintenance role in the derailment
region per the union there used to be
something called maintenance and if you
read the article you learn a lot about
what is going on in the world of trains
One Union rail One Union of rail workers
is questioned declining maintenance
standards following the derailment
a device that can play a role in
preventing derailments is the Wayside
HotBox detector it uses infrared sensors
to detect bearings axles or other
components that are overheating and then
it uses radio signals to flag rail Crews
of any overheated components the rail
car that initiated the derailment we now
know had an overheated wheel bearing
according to a report from the NTSB
Wayside HotBox detectors are usually
placed every 25 miles along a railroad
their use has contributed to a 59
percent decrease in train accidents
caused by axle and bearing related
factors since 1990. declining head
counts have led to these mechanisms
receiving less preventative maintenance
according to an official from the
Brotherhood of Railroad signalmen Union
the fra has no regulations requiring the
use or maintenance of HotBox detectors a
hotbox detector in East Palestine
notified the crew moments before the
Train derailed it's unclear if any
HotBox detector prior to East Palestine
notified Crews a surveillance video
shared on Facebook from an industrial
facility in Salem Ohio 20 miles from
East Palestine suggests the Train's axle
was already on fire
so there are a lot of components to this
and I have friends in the railroad
industry and I've been talking to them
all about this and we are not yet at the
point where we can definitively say the
problem was not enough of these Hot Box
detectors
and part of the reason why there weren't
enough is that there is no minimum
requirement for where they have to be
there are recommendations but not a
typically they are every 25 miles but
there is no actual requirement so one
possible explanation here and again
we're all trying to learn about what
happened one possible explanation here
is
surveillance video showed that there
already appeared to be a fire on the
train 20 miles away 20 miles away
from where it eventually derailed and if
indeed there was no hot box detector
there even though the recommendation is
that there should have been that is an
argument that were were it a requirement
to have those hot box detectors they
might have been notified about this fire
which eventually led to the derailment
as many as 20 miles earlier at which
point you could have stopped the Train
the fire would not have been nearly as
big and you could have conceivably
prevented the derailment altogether so
that would be an example of how there is
under regulation there's the
recommendation of where to place the
HotBox detectors but there is not the
requirement
so it's a chain of decisions and things
that take place with regulation coming
down from the top now we also know that
more generally there's another issue
here which is Norfolk Southern wants to
make as much money as they can and we
have reports that Norfolk Southern Cut
workers cut maintenance and opted not to
do
as much in terms of expenditures on new
Safety Systems when they didn't have to
all of that in order to save on expenses
and to make more money and then the
third element of this of course and I
told you this last week or the week
before there were additional
requirements placed on trains by the
Obama Administration which were repealed
under the Trump Administration in 2018.
I'm not going to redo that story now
because we all I already told you the
details of that Obama putting in place
these things and the Trump
Administration rolling them back
so we are still building up our exact
understanding of what took place here
but it is increasingly pointing to a
story about under regulation where we
know the technology that can prevent
these things we know that when the
technology is used these events
decreased dramatically and that was not
in place in this particular case we will
soon know for sure whether that was the
cause but the early report says it was
so remember when the right says we're
over regulated everywhere there may be
over regulation in some places and I'm
certainly open to we should have a
reason for regulations that are put in
place but removing regulations for the
sake of saying we've removed regulations
not only doesn't make any sense it also
is extraordinarily dangerous when you're
looking at situations like this we will
have links to all of these stories I've
been putting up on the screen in the
description to the YouTube videos for
these stories you can find find the
YouTube channel at youtube.com the
davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
lest anyone forget the David pakman show
is a viewer and listener supported
program not only do we produce the daily
podcasts the daily radio show The Daily
TV show The Daily YouTube show The Daily
YouTube clips the daily Facebook Clips
the daily Instagram Clips the daily Tick
Tock clips and the live streams we also
now are producing a dubbed Spanish
version of the show for YouTube uh
pushing Beyond 1500 subscribers in the
early days there and it is all funded by
memberships people who sign up at
joinpakman.com I would invite you to do
so we do an extra show every day for our
members and you can use the coupon code
24 starts now at joinpakman.com to get a
discount and remember that's
p-a-k-m-a-n many people email me they
say sir I tried going to join Pac-Man
with p-a-c-k and it didn't sign me up
and there's a reason why which is it's
not how how my last name is spelled join
pacman.com coupon code 24 Starts Now
check it out Donald Trump held an event
yesterday at Club 45 which I guess the
renaming club 47 because they want Trump
to be the 47th president or something
this was such a confusing event during
which Donald Trump visibly struggles to
drink water at one point it's really
weird he takes questions from children
and still can't answer them in any
sensible way I don't know what the hell
this guy is doing but he is incredibly
desperate for relevance he's desperate
for sycophants to suck up to him which I
guess he doesn't feel Fox News and Wall
Street Journal are doing anymore to the
degree that he wants let's look at this
this first clip
Trump takes a question from a kid who's
wearing a trump one shirt and remember
the right is worried that the left is
indoctrinating children think about that
as you listen to this
uh hello Mr President I love that shirt
it's so beautiful oh thank you he's got
to share Trump one
[Music]
they're cheering that they are teaching
a kid to believe things that simply
aren't true after you become the 47th
president what are you gonna do to stop
the war in Ukraine yeah so I would
literally start calling not from the day
I took over but from the night I won and
I called two people two people you know
the two people are Putin right your
opportunities and zielinsky zielinski
and I'd say we're gonna meet we're gonna
tell me what it said he would get on the
phone and he'll go we're gonna be
and I would I I guarantee I could work
that out oh man I guarantee I know
exactly what I'd say by the way I know
exactly I tell one guy this and I tell
one guy that and I say you better make a
deal Trump's foreign policy ideas
extremely convincing to nine-year-olds I
think that that if it if there's any big
uh ringing endorsement if there's any
bigger ringing endorsement I can't think
of one
um here's another really crazy one this
guy is almost in tears it really seems
like Trump is taking questions from
random people which is totally fine I
actually think it would be imagine if a
president more regularly took questions
from random people I think that that's
great the problem is these people
they're such delusional sycophants
president Trump I'd like to say it's a
great honor to be in the same room with
you by the way for all I know this isn't
a random person and it's like some
fundraising guy or who knows thank you
it's my honor
and also I'd also like to thank you
for your sacrifice yeah to the people of
this country thank you really a martyr
who gave up his great life to help us
hurting us people don't understand you
had it made in the shade
and you stuck your neck out for us
that's true
[Applause]
oh dear God what this is this is the
United States in 2023
this is the front runner to be the
Republican nominee for the presidency of
the United States Trump then pulling out
his famous n-word rant which he just
loves nuclear is so devastating that we
don't even want to talk about it and
there was a word that was never supposed
to be mentioned
give two n-words neither of which should
ever be mentioned I said that once I
said oh what a terrible thing to say no
you have two n-words you know what the
one is but the other is the nuclear word
not supposed to ever be mentioned ever
ever ever
right but Trump's gonna say the N word
for us I guess when he talks to Putin as
he likes to say
um no Trump event is a complete without
Trump complaining about the 2020
election which is now uh closing in on
three years ago and indeed he did
there's no way you could lose the
election and we got close to 75 million
votes and that's only what they agreed
to that's only what they say it's much
higher than that but they agree to it so
we got
based on that we get 12 million more
votes right
and we lost
her there and you know when you look oh
pencil I guess he's at least admitting
he lost maybe how about Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania was over at 10 o'clock and
then all of a sudden they had a large
drop a dump yeah by the way did you
notice he's no longer saying dump he's
now saying drop now these people are
really uh it's so sad it's so sad I mean
there's no way so anyway Trump bemoaning
that election that just got away it just
got away from him really projecting
Incredible strength with winding three
years on Trump then is asked a question
by Ashton who I guess is like a young
reporter a young Republican reporter
and he can't even answer these these
softball questions in a way that makes
sense hi Mr President my name is Ashton
I'm the
person very impressive
yes so good as the club and as young
people what is the Strategic campaign
messaging to reach Millennials in
Tennessee
well I look I said I have one little
phrase that I think became the most
powerful phrase in the history of
politics and maybe
in any country you know what the phrase
is make America great again
that's gonna be his messaging to Young
People by the way it's the same
messaging that got him almost no youth
vote in 2016 and almost no youth vote in
2020. that's his message you go into
details and you know what the details
because we've been talking about them
the whole night
make America great again another one
America first we put America first right
they're putting them that's really going
to resonate with Gen Z you can just tell
um at another point a completely
indoctrinated Super Fan of trump says
what can we do to fight for you what can
we do and Trump says I need your undying
support this is literally a cult it it
it meets all of the requirements of a
cult
thank you very much so my question is
since you're fighting for us what do you
want us to do to fight for you
[Applause]
support your support and not even
monetary support I mean what we need is
your absolute undying support and we
have other places throughout the country
where the spirit we've never seen Spirit
like we see it right now and I think
Donnie that spirit that support uh and
we can't be stopped and once we're there
we're going to fix this country yep he's
going to fix it as soon as he gets a
shot I mean okay he had four years and
he made the country worse in so many
ways but this time you can believe him
this time he really is going to fix it
someone in the audience wanted Trump to
weigh in on whether a T and T should be
dismantled which is not exactly small
government Behavior it's not exactly the
lightest Touch of Regulation that
Republicans claim to want but
um DirecTV dropped Newsmax and so now
what about dismantling a t thank you
yeah
1982 a t was dismantled because it
became too big to for its bridges at T
subsidiary DirecTV just banned Newsmax
yeah broadcasting is it time to
dismantle at T again because it's
getting too big for its bridges yeah the
small government crowd that is against
regulation is calling for the government
to destroy a business thank you sir
a t is a lousy company it's highly over
levered it's run by radical left people
honestly it's doing so badly you know
normally you dismantle when they're
doing so well at T is doing badly they
got rid of uh they took it and DirecTV
which I guess they own and they got rid
of nismix and hopefully they'll put it
back and oan also oan was fantastic and
still was fantastic but it's a struggle
for them because they're being
de-platformed they've de-platform me and
now they're all begging for me to come
back you know why because they're dying
out there without us
that's why truth is so good that's why
truth is so good but you know what I
mean is like a lousy company it's
leveraged to the hilt it uh it's doing
very poorly and yet they get rid of a
Newsmax and an oan who actually both got
very good ratings and I think there's a
lot of pressure being put up a t dropped
you know their stock since that time
yeah the guy in the crowd is all is very
much aware of that
um so just a completely unhinged event
in every single way there was the most
interesting moment was where Donald
Trump seemed to acknowledge something I
said yesterday which is some of the
people that are getting into this race
against Trump which is really just Nikki
Haley it may be less about winning than
about auditioning to be Trump's VP and
Trump seems to be saying exactly that a
lot of people are right now auditioning
you know that a lot of people a lot of
people that are running at one percent
two percent three percent no percent
we have a couple that are joining
they're at no percent
I say I wonder what they're doing I
think they're auctioning right now for
they're auditioning right now auctioning
they're auctioning uh no try I don't
think Trump's wrong and in fact I think
this is one of the possibilities when it
comes to Nikki Haley
um as to why she is not drawing a single
policy distinction with Trump so there
it is Trump addressing supporters and
and taking questions good for him for
taking questions it's just the questions
are insane and the answers are even
crazier that's the only downside but
it's a beautiful thing I think to take
questions from supporters uh let's now
focus in on the DeSantis part
I'm separating out a couple of moments
from yesterday's deranged and delusional
event that Donald Trump did in Florida
where he is just going after Ron
DeSantis or as he knows him wrong run to
sanctimonious not meet ball Ron at least
not as far as we know so far this is a
building Civil War
but it is between
a guy who's running for president and a
guy who right now isn't actually running
for president Ron DeSantis hasn't
announced anything but Ron DeSantis even
without announcing is polling so
strongly relative to Trump winning in
some polls losing in others but polling
very strongly for a guy who's not
running that Donald Trump is threatened
Donald Trump's ego is threatened Donald
Trump's a path to Victory is threatened
now I do think at the end of the day
Trump is going to run circles around
DeSantis in a national campaign because
of the Optics I don't think DeSantis is
up for what it will take to defeat Trump
in a national campaign but regardless
Trump is feeling threatened so Trump is
regularly going after Ron DeSantis who
he claims on Truth social all the time
he never thinks about he told us last
week I never think about the guy and yet
he brings him up here is Donald Trump
bringing up the crowd size it's the same
old stuff folks the crowd size that Ron
DeSantis didn't get a big crowd in New
York yesterday and not only does this
mean Trump is thinking about Ron
DeSantis he's also paying attention to
desantis's events we're there actually
and it was really good it was really it
dies and everybody thought it was great
and about two three days later oh there
didn't seem to be much energy they'll
even take this crowd you know Rhonda
sanctimonious had a crowd and Staten
Island to that
139 people and said now we got a lot of
people we have 139 times about 30. the
audio clearly being run by antifa during
this event
we got a lot of people here but I always
say
hit your enemy a little bit early some
people say don't but I say do but you
know yeah so there is Trump hitting the
enemy early as he says that which is a
completely deranged language to be using
in these circumstances against the guy
who hasn't even announced that he's
running and then in another moment
during this Trump mentioned the um vote
differential between DeSantis for
governor and Trump for president
continuing to try to uh it's basically a
penis size contest well and I never
mentioned this because I don't like
hitting Republicans I really don't right
but I did get 1.2 million more votes
than Ron 1.2 million more wow nobody
wants their mention the Press refuses to
mention it we'll have to talk to our
club 47 people about this
they don't want to mention good thing no
I got 1.2 million votes more than Ron
and Ron did good in Florida but I did
great yeah so basically all the hits at
this event I mean there was almost
nothing missing from Trump's routine
from this weird event okay he didn't do
obamac that's true that that was missing
but short of that really doing all the
old tricks so Trump will be um in East
Palestine Ohio tomorrow I don't know if
there's going to be any kind of live
event if there is we might look at
covering it if Joe Biden visits East
Palestine Ohio we will also cover it and
all of the clips these these thick and
Meaty clips that I played for you today
you can find all of them on our
Instagram by going to Instagram and
searching for David Pacman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today I'm
going to be speaking with Matthew remsky
who's a freelance journalist writing
about religious cults and also co-host
of the conspirituality podcast is that
the way you say it or is it Khan's
spirituality we usually de-emphasize the
first syllable but we can talk about why
um I mean conspirituality is good so let
I mean I think that will will give us a
good kind of entry point into some of
the subject matter that you talk about
just to pick some thing and every time I
I Broach these topics invariably there
are people in my audience who get upset
sometimes misunderstanding what I'm
saying about whether it be Homeopathy or
yoga or Reiki or cupping or whatever
okay but just to pick something because
you have some experience with it let's
talk a little bit about yoga yoga is
interesting because it is a form of sort
of exercise and a physical a practice
and also tied in with it is some woo
sometimes and a spirituality element and
some practitioners just like you see
with different modalities will make more
claims than others about the supposed
benefits of something like yoga so let's
start there I mean what talk about your
experience with yoga benefits of the
practice that we know are evidence-based
and where things sometimes go beyond
that well I'm glad that you're starting
here because I've done a lot of years
doing cultural criticism on Yoga and
Wellness and the Cults associated with
them and sometimes I do forget
um the benefits what actually got me
interested in the first place why this
is a thing why it's a huge industry uh
and I think you know the the evidence
question is actually quite
um you know the the the cards are the
the judgment is still not in because
it's very difficult to do science on
yoga but I think the basic benefits that
everybody agrees on is that you can use
postures and stretching and mindful
breathing to get more familiar with your
bodily reality uh and maybe befriend it
a little bit more and I think for most
Global North you know American European
practitioners there was a time in which
those simple benefits were basically the
focus of what the practice had to offer
there was a period in the 70s the elite
60s maybe when yoga was largely
associated with simply loosening up
one's body and psychology becoming more
receptive and creative and maybe even
supporting the project of reimagining
society in gentler terms and a lot of
people would have transformative moments
with the postures and breathing they
might let go of of certain patterns of
social conditioning and expectations I
was a kind of exercise of mellowing out
or even dropping out but that's actually
between you know this sort of rigid
post-war Don Draper era fordist economy
and then you know Gordon Gekko starting
to get to the gym in the 1980s with a
kind of just do it physical culture that
begins to integrate with yoga in a very
profound uh manner where yoga becomes
something that you do to become more
self-sufficient not necessarily more
open or empathetic with other people and
I think strain actually when that
happened
some of it happening through till today
yoga as a culture began to remember and
even emphasize some of the early 20th
century themes that tied it to Fascism
for example which I'm sure we'll get
into
but the benefits are simple you know
like if you stay away from Instagram and
Lululemon and Psychopaths like Bikram
Chowdhury like everybody can have a late
1960s yoga moment because it's not the
clothes or the technique or the
alignment it's not green smoothies it's
just you know breathing deeply through a
choreography of postures focusing on
Sensations and emotions that can give a
lot of relief especially if you're
extremely online overly extroverted you
know disconnected with your body they're
really simple gifts you can enjoy them
at home without becoming compulsive or
without turning yoga into some kind of
like side hustle in a gig economy which
is what a lot of gen xers like myself
and then also Millennials actually did
For Better or Worse right so there's all
these other areas that we could explore
there's the kind of commoditizing yoga
uh into the franchise is business a
for-profit and sort of like that aspect
of it there's the way in which what you
just talked about as the benefits start
to be kind of built upon more and more
and more sometimes by charismatic for
lack of a better term what become cult
leaders in some cases and and we've
talked about there's all these different
directions that we could go with this
let's maybe start with the latter a
little bit what are the sorts of
promises about yoga that sometimes are
made which then open the door down to
the more sort of like cult-like aspects
of this well I would say that um the
promises are totalizing in the yoga
world uh that not only is it about
health and wellness but there's also
this spiritual element that is spoken
about
um it's part of a self-project that many
teachers will also speak about being
related to you know a global Awakening
of Consciousness this was very big
through the 60s and 70s
um and you know it's part of a general
historical turn away from you know
Community participation and towards the
self project and so ideas of personal
health and you know heightening your
immunity and you know avoiding
conventional medicine become wrapped up
in this as well
and the problem is is that is that like
the definitions for what yoga practice
is are very vague very subjective
um it's not like there are any real
standards for how we can assess the
competence of yoga teaching
um and what tends to rise to the top in
terms of Industry leadership is you know
you used the word before is the
charismatic you know in the absence of
being able to really sort of prove that
you are
a competent or a even a safe yoga
teacher what you can do is you can show
that you perform the appearance of
equanimity or even Enlightenment really
well now that all gets heightened in the
visual age of Instagram of course but
the problem with Charisma is that you
know not all charismatics become cult
leaders but all cult leaders are in some
way charismatic and Charisma is kind of
like this organizational principle
people in the cultic dynamic where
there's some sort of mysterious
undefined power that a single person or
idea has at the center of a group and
that draws sort of energy towards that
power center uh and away from you know
Mutual Aid and sharing and horizontal
relationships what are some of the
warning signs if you're in and we can
stick with yoga but we could talk about
elsewhere what are some of the warning
signs that you might not be going to
just like a yoga class but this may be
more of the one that's that's the
cult-like thing yeah I mean Silver
Bullet claims about your health uh about
your physical health your mental health
um the teacher who suggests that such
and such a posture is good for the
reproductive system or for liver
cleansing or for depression
um these are all medical claims and they
are they are absolutely ubiquitous
throughout the yoga World in fact like
the primary textbook written in 1966 by
bksi younger it's called light on yoga
and it's like I don't know 300 600 pages
long or maybe it's 300 pages long with
600 plates but every single posture has
an unsubstantiated medical claim
attached to it right that emerges out of
a you know an earlier time it's not like
this guy is a charlatan trying to pull
wool over people's eyes but there's this
General sort of epistemological
um I don't know lack of rigor in the
industry that ends up you know confusing
the pleasures of stretching and deep
breathing with feeling like there's some
sort of magical healing going on and so
you know Silver Bullet claims are a real
red flag I would also say that you know
there's a feeling of you know I don't
know uh contradictory
authoritarianism versus personal
autonomy I I would call it like the tone
Tony Robbins lie right like like you pay
me and you do exactly what I say and
you'll experience total personal freedom
um as long as you keep paying me and
doing exactly what I say exactly yeah
right um then there's the problem of of
intrusive eye contact which I think
people can identify if you know if
they're on YouTube now they can flip
over to Teal Swan and see how she does
that
um and then there's humorlessness I have
never ever met a wellness influencer or
yoga grifter or yoga cult leader I've
never encountered anybody in that whole
Echelon that has a sense of humor that
can laugh at themselves they're just
really puffed up and defensive and and
usually anxious because I think usually
what they're what they're selling is
built on nothing you know as in hearing
you talk about some of the things you
mentioned I've had not with the the
later characteristics here but when I've
gone to massage therapists which I don't
do often because I find it all a little
bit awkward and I also really don't like
the oil which gets everywhere I'll tell
you
um I often they will it'll be a
completely you know find massage and
then at the end they'll say you know
massage can release a lot of toxins into
the body so make sure to drink a lot of
water to then flush them out and
immediately I'm thinking wait a second
so water we're talking about kidneys
some toxins are processed through the
liver you massage me and I lit Google is
there any scientific basis for that and
of course there is no scientific basis
for that right but it's just kind of
part of the whole experience it's and
it's it's so casually inserted in there
I think one of the things that's going
on in that encounter too is that they're
saying you're going to be sore after
right just manhandled you and I think
you should take care of yourself and
actually this kind of soreness or even
Afterglow of pain is part of something
that's good and and it establishes I'm
not saying the person is trying to rip
you off but I think it establishes the
kind of
um thought process by which you think oh
the consumer begins to feel like oh uh
something is coming out of me I'm in a
process of purification yeah I'm getting
straight with myself I'm renewing myself
I'm shedding my old skin and that's a
kind of Rhythm that can be really easily
monetized I think because often the
answer to soreness from massage is more
massage right in the same way that that
the answer to pain from yoga is often
presented as doing more yoga right
what um what happened during the
pandemic that sent this is not unique to
yoga but we can talk about it that way
if it's more you know if you're more
precise in that particular category that
kind of sent yoga folks down into the
conspiracy Rabbit Hole in some other
areas
well a lot of things happened that
flowed together to really create a
perfect storm
um we have a lot of people who are
suddenly locked out of their places of
Wellness but also sometimes
um you know spiritual worship and
they're starting to spend all of their
time at home online the online space is
very flat very competitive
um you know March and April of 2020 you
couldn't go onto Facebook without seeing
like 25 people in my feed offering yoga
classes out of their dining room on
Facebook live and trying trying to get
paid by venmo
now the the industry and the community
already is susceptible to conspiracy
theories to magical thinking to a kind
of um well let's define the term
conspirality which is a an integration
or an intersection between political
conspiracy theorizing and New Age
Promises of wellness and renewal right
and it's not just an intersection it's
kind of like the two things are
dependent it's because things are so bad
in the world that we are being called to
awaken it's because they are developing
vaccines at a very fast rate that we
urgently must improve our immune system
so that we don't get microchipped so
there's kind of like a
um you know sort of a media strip of
anxiety and promises that begin to take
over the online space
and what people found was that the
closer they got towards you know literal
Q Anon uh fever dream conspiracy
material the more more popular they
became
and we have a number of examples of
people who who vastly increase their
followings because they started pill you
know posting red pill material
now what happened and what was quite
tragic was that they might have had an
affinity for these ideas but it's not
like they had full commitment or
necessarily knew exactly that oh this
this is a blood libel fantasy oh this is
actually part of the satanic Panic
that's being extended from the 1980s
they may not have been aware of any of
that but by the time they invested their
online identities with you know
promoting that material some of them
really lost a lot of contact with not
only their business you know sort of uh
Market but also with their families
um and so I did a lot of reporting on
the follow-up after that first acute
phase and there was a lot of people who
were like I really you know I don't
really believe in in Q Anon and I want
to with you know I I was just trying to
share information and uh I really just
want to do the yoga and of course then
there's a some small percentage of
people who are still sort of building
their brand on this very anxious and a
very potent mix of conspiracy theories
and spiritual promises like the world is
terrible and here's the spiritual answer
which has to be which has to be total
it's not just that you're going to avoid
the the vaccines it's that you're going
to look into my eyes and we're going to
experience the the face of God together
and everything's going to be okay
last thing I want to ask you about what
are some new new age or spiritual things
that are going on that maybe I or my
audience haven't heard of because
there's so you know I find these
fascinating in a lot of different ways
and we've talked about everything from
you know crystals to
um I mean just all these different
things what's the new stuff that's
coming up now uh you know we have a
correspondent on our podcast named
Mallory DeMille and she's The Tick Tock
correspondent and so she looks into
things like you know the Healy
biofeedback machine and she looks into
light language tick-tockers and we might
send her on a a neo-pagan hunt
um we also also there's a very
disturbing Trend developing on Tick Tock
that um involves a lot of conspiracy
theories amongst very young people who
consider themselves to be starseeds or
alien children or indigo children who
believe that 2023 is actually a
portentous time uh for for world
destruction and they're folding in sort
of weird stories about the weather
balloons and UFOs and the trains but
that's basically just end time stuff
right stuff yeah but but things on Tick
Tock can can accelerate at an alarming
Pace uh and and and get people really
revved up but I mean what I have
resolved to do after spending like three
years now in the mud of this stuff is I
tried to look for like spiritual
organizations or movements that
um are trying to sort of account for
this material they're trying to do
something and you know sometimes it's
hard to find uh places where I I feel
like oh I would attend that or yeah are
there any well you know when whenever I
come into I don't want to endorse
anybody directly yeah yeah uh but but
whenever I come into contact with
something that makes sense uh that feels
like it's grounded in reality you know
it's going to be like a black church
it's going to be a First Nations
ceremony Community it's going to be like
an lgbtq plus support group like
anything that's just purely associated
with self-help or self-work or the self
project I just don't find very
compelling uh anymore personally and I
also think it remains vulnerable to this
kind of like hyper in individualistic
very reactionary politics inviting and
and soaked kind of environment uh that
that I just find really toxic I mean I
don't know what the human spirit is uh
but I I do find that the people who are
creating the deepest sources of meaning
are in these groups that are doing
something to sort of account for their
place in society to resist some of the
excesses of late capitalism you know
they're debating the best ways forward
in transparent ways they focus on
everyday work and you know just normal
things like parenting and Community Care
well I'm reading between the lines and
I'm not hearing an endorsement for
Deepak Chopra in what you're saying no
you're not you're not actually because
because because there's something
extremely elitist and unaffordable yeah
aside from the pseudosciences aside from
aside from his his relationships with
you know
um influencers who are peddling all
kinds of of conspiracy stuff uh yeah
it's it's just inaccessible and I think
that's good actually yes strange way it
should be more difficult to get sucked
into it I agree with that right uh we've
been speaking with Matthew remsky
co-host of the conspirituality podcast
also a freelance journalist really
appreciate your time and insights today
thank you David thank you so much
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
I have to hand it to Piers Morgan last
week it was Carrie Lake and this week
it's George Anthony devolder Santos who
show up and they get absolutely
brutalized by Piers Morgan this is
really fascinating stuff George Santos
the lying Republican Congressman to his
credit he showed up clearly having
received some media training over the
last few weeks you can tell he's just a
little more polished and a little bit
more poised but still horribly dishonest
he agreed to take questions from Piers
Morgan and uh it is absolutely
fascinating to see this in this first
clip George Santos defends his lie about
being Jewish by saying it's a joke he's
Jewish and that everybody in the past
thought it was funny and this is clearly
a very sick individual if I always made
this as a party favorite joke and it's
I've done it on stages
a Jew no no no not falsely claiming I'm
Jewish I would always say I'm I was
raised Catholic but I come from a Jewish
family so that makes me Jewish but again
it's always been a party favor
everybody's always loud it's been a
party favorite or favor I don't even
know what he's saying not everybody's
canceling me everybody's pounding down
for a pound just because you're not
Jewish
never said I was
and I would always say but my
grandparents are Jewish on my mother's
side so I'm Jewish that was always a
joke everybody used to laugh it up guys
don't you know the joke it's so funny
but it said it's a room with a thousand
people in November people were
hysterically laughing it was funny to
them they loved it I don't think Jewish
people find it funny but there's another
thing here also which is important to
mention which is
it's different to as an obvious joke in
a room during a live event to say I
consider myself Jewish and make it clear
that it's a joke versus the numerous
statements numerous statements where he
said Jewish lineage my parents the
grandparents Holocaust this these are
two dramatically different things or do
you wish I was in a room with the
Republicans people find it funny that a
U.S congressman he's a Catholic with no
apparent background of any Jewish
Heritage whatsoever other than you say
you have it no one can find it I think a
lot of Jewish people would find that
offensive I I begged it for when we were
at the RJC in November well no no no no
no it's obvious that Jewish people find
it offensive and it's become abundantly
clear he's like no nobody finds it
offensive at all uh nice job there by
Piers Morgan pointing out the absurdity
of this
um the other fascinating moment from
this interview
was when George desantos George De
Santos
oh boy that that is quite a Freudian
slip George Santos
um
George desantos George Santos says the
Republican Party basically made him
fabricate his background in order to
like be taken more seriously or
something like that Superstar I was this
my family with this and it was all
untrue so I don't categorize these as
mistakes I think that part of your
process a cathartic process of
redemption if you like it's gonna start
from I've been a terrible liar I mean
would you be prepared to say that sure
like I said well I've been a terrible
liar on those subjects and and what what
I tried to convey to the American people
is
I things that were untrue is what he
tried to convey made mistakes of
allowing the pressures of what I thought
needed to be done in order to this
you guys did you see that his mistake
was he let his misunderstanding of
pressure to say things that weren't true
make him lie like it's this is like an
as I apologize if people were offended
this wasn't about tricking anybody this
wasn't about just it's it's sexy no no
no no no let me find it was about
tricking let me finish it wasn't about
tricking to the people this was about
getting accepted by the party right he
had to lie because otherwise the
Republican Party wouldn't accept him
um now sadly this is all sort of part of
the George Santos Rehabilitation tour
and it's becoming increasingly clear
that if nothing changes he's going to be
able to say in the House of
Representatives he'll probably serve one
term and then be soundly removed he is
off of all of his committees it will be
a meaningless term but it is
increasingly looking like he's going to
be able to say but don't worry everybody
because he's decided he's not going to
lie anymore now here was an interesting
revelation
he says
in terms of why did you think you could
get away with it he says I ran in 2020
and told the same lies and no one
noticed that they were lies then he
never got a Masters in Business at New
York no not like I said no right
I mean again did you not think people
would find this out you know Pierce not
after I you're not wanting to be like a
reality TV no no I understand you know
if you if you were going on Celebrity
Apprentice which I went on right it
doesn't matter you can embellish stuff
about yourself nobody cares right but to
run for Congress of the United States
and to
just tell blatant lies about even your
academic record I'm just struck not
necessarily that a politician would lie
but that you would think no one would
find out well
I'll humor you this I ran in 2020 for
the same exact seat
um for Congress and I got away with it
then and I guess
why
well that's honest stupid so you thought
actually they don't they're not gonna
find out no I don't think so
so he's like I told the same lies two
years ago and nobody uh nobody noticed
and then um asked about if he knew that
there would be this Firestorm would he
even have run for office and he says no
I would not are you dealing with the
complete loss of your anonymity now
what's it been like for you to be George
Central summer streets in America well
it's it's uncomfortable uh think about
it this way just last night he's the
real victim guys hey we my husband and I
went out to the movies and you know as
I'm walking from getting the tickets to
get to the concession stand to get to
the theater that's just that it Whispers
all across the movie theater so it's
just very strange you know because part
of you like it as much as part of he
finds it uncomfortable I can't stand it
and a lot of people think I love it I
just can't stand it it's something I'm
going to have to learn how to deal with
because as as you said earlier when we
were talking uh before taping once that
Genie is out of the bottle right you
can't put it back in so you need to
learn how to live with it and just
that's what I'm doing if you know what
was what a tough victim huh going to
happen to you in terms of the ferocity
of the attention you know you're
currently you've got eight different
official investigations into you you
know people have called you the biggest
liar in the world you know all this
stuff if you'd known what was going to
happen would you have still wanted to
run for office absolutely not yeah so
there it is he would not have run if
that was the case that he knew this was
going to happen so listen the interview
is pathetic he's clearly been coached to
some degree about how to answer some of
these things he's strategically you know
saying I was wrong about this I was
wrong about that but but still kind of
saying I was forced into all of it and
these were embellishments and all of
this sort of thing
but he's going to be allowed to stay it
seems to me I believe that he has
weathered the height of the pressure and
I I would love to keep pressuring him
and I will but I don't think it makes a
difference if it's me doing it it seems
as though the
um Storm Is Passing and he'll kind of be
allowed to ring linger Without Really
accomplishing anything until he's voted
out in 2024 would be my guess I am going
to play for you something that is
amazing videos of Ron DeSantis talking
about foreign policy or trying to and
it's really really funny who would have
guessed that Ron DeSantis trying to talk
about foreign policy would be so funny
we have uh I I don't even know how or
where to start this Rhonda santis did an
event yesterday in Staten Island which
is the most conservative of the five New
York City boroughs I've only been once
to be honest other than driving through
but it's not a place I'm super familiar
with but I know on paper it is the most
conservative of the five boroughs he did
an event there and he also appeared on
Fox News during the Fox News appearance
here is Ron DeSantis downplaying the
threat that Russia poses to other
countries typical talking point trumpian
talking point so far following in the
line of trump
um and really putting together
with completely kind of Clueless tone a
very similar foreign policy
idea or framework as that which we have
seen from Maga Governor what does a win
look like for us in Ukraine for Ukraine
well I think it's important to point out
I mean you know the fear of kind of
Russia going into NATO countries and all
that and steamrolling you know that has
not even come close to happening I think
they've shown themselves to be a
third-rate military power I think
they've suffered tremendous tremendous
losses I got to think that the people in
Russia are probably disapproving of
what's going on I don't think they can
speak up about it for obvious reasons so
I think Russia has been really really
wounded here they're really the ones
that have had it tough you know I don't
think that they are the same threat to
our country even though they're hostile
I don't think they're on the same level
as a China yep China is increasingly
pronouncing that
um so this is this is a typical Playbook
okay this is I'm not going to come out
and say the things that a lot of the
people that would vote for me are
thinking
which is like they actually kind of like
Putin they're enamored with these
authoritarian strongmen uh but he's
gonna just say yeah you know there's not
really that much of a thread and we
don't really have to worry that much and
it's really Russia that's been hurt by
all of this and uh the U.S getting
behind Ukraine is actually like really
bad for the Russian people and so on and
so forth but the funniest part of it is
you know Florida Governor tries to talk
about foreign policy and clearly has no
idea what so whatsoever what's going on
here he was asked during the same
interview about
um the visit to Ukraine is this the same
interview or was this later in the day I
believe it is the same interview
um asked about the visit to Ukraine by
Joe Biden and you won't be shocked to
know that uh he doesn't like it things
first on the president's unannounced
visit is this a good move
well you know Brian I'm reminded of uh
when he was Vice President Obama and
Biden uh opposed providing lethal Aid to
Ukraine during those years and then I'm
also reminded that I don't think any of
this would have happened but for the
weakness that the president showed
during his first year in office
culminating of course right in the
disastrous withdrawal in Afghanistan so
I think while he's over there I think I
and many Americans are thinking to
ourselves okay he's very concerned about
those borders Halfway Around the World
he's not done anything to secure our own
border here at home we've had he's on
message right I mean this is what the
other Republicans said millions and
millions of people pour in tens of
thousands of Americans dead because of
Fentanyl and then of course we just
suffered a national humiliation of
having China fly a spy balloon clear
across the continental United States so
we have a lot of problems accumulating
here in our own country that he is
neglecting this is the language of
someone who's running for president I
don't know how else to say it this is a
message that this is not a Florida
message this is a message you give in
New York
about global issues that you understand
very little about and look at by the way
when you look at that clip and the
previous one and what we know about
DeSantis take a look at the foreign
policy sort of package that DeSantis is
putting together blaming the United
States for the Russian invasion of
Ukraine and Biden's alleged mishandling
of things
um attacking Biden while Biden is in a
war zone right because at the end of the
day that's where Joe Biden went
suggesting he would dial back support
for Ukraine and give Russia a more
breathing room to do what it wants to do
minimizing the threat from Russia of
course saying that he was against the
Afghanistan withdrawal even though Trump
was going to do the exact same
withdrawal and when asked Trump didn't
even articulate that he would have done
anything differently
and of course scaling it up with
aggressive talk about China which may or
may not be warranted based on the facts
but it's just his his favorite thing
we're China this China this China that
um this is a guy who does very much seem
to be setting up a run for president and
one that is going to be horrifying when
it comes to foreign policy by the way a
quick look at his event here in Staten
Island and you can see it is an
extremely diverse crowd of a few dozen
white men I think I see one woman in the
audience but basically an
extraordinarily
diverse crowd of white men who were
eager to see DeSantis speak
um why I don't even know uh it's it's
all extraordinarily strange he will
probably announce pretty soon will be my
guess we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P yesterday on the
bonus show we talked about the culinary
scam that is the boneless chicken wing
it's not a wing and a lot of people
called in here's one voicemail
hey David you know I was listening to
the the explanation he gave around the
terrible false advertising with boneless
chicken wings
you know they're not real wings at all
it would be like you know somebody
taking a liquid made from soy or almonds
or something like that and then coin it
something like milk which is not at all
you know you just use that marketing
because it sounds better you know as Pat
was saying listen we talked about this
you can make a case that almond milk
shouldn't be labeled as milk because
it's not milk you could make the case
that a boneless wing shouldn't be called
a wing because it's a chicken breast
right or a tenderloin my view on this is
sort of uh uh if we agree that we can
name things based on their usage almond
milk and oat milk are used functionally
as milks and that would be an argument
for saying you can call it milk the
Counterpoint would be and this is the
one that big Dairy says it's not milk
and therefore you can't really call it
milk I don't know what the answer is but
it's getting very very complicated we
have have a great bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpackman.com I'll
see you then